and the fact that most of you are not
taking advantage of this opportunity
because of the insecurities that your
[__] up parents or your neighborhood
gave to you breaks my [__] heart
attention is the number one asset if
you're 47 years old and you think you're
finished you need to rethink everything
shit's happening and you need to take
advantage of your thing and the fact
that most of you are not taking
advantage of this opportunity because of
the insecurities that your [__] up
parents or your neighborhood gave to you
breaks my [__] heart I am so
frustrated by watching all the teenagers
and 20-year-olds take full advantage of
this opportunity because they don't know
any better and for the 40 and 50 and 60
year olds closing their mind without
realizing that they're going to live for
the next 40 years and this [__] land
grab is for you too and good news old
[__] you have
experience